we're talking about uh kids do you
expose your kids to music and movies
that you liked when you were a kid
because i always that's the experience i
like is i like this when i was a kid and
i want them to see it yeah um
i just recently
showed them e.t which was really fun so
it's it's so great and it ends up and
it's yeah really holds up and afterwards
i asked my kids like what do you think
of et and
my daughter said that for halloween she
wants to be dead e.t with flaky white
skin and black eyes
what kid chooses dead e.t i don't know
but now i have to get that costume
together
that's such a strange choice last year
she was uh dead abraham lincoln so i
think
it'd probably be easier
well she's got a goth on your hand yeah
exactly
uh let me ask you about uh the amazing
amy poehler of course plays your wife
yes on parks and recreation and then in
uh in this movie acod
she plays your stepmom yeah
yeah she plays my stepmom and we totally
hate each other in the movie it was
really fun um
but when we were making i started
thinking like i actually kind of wish
amy was my real stepmom in real life
because i think she would be a pretty
cool
stepmom like she would
she would totally let me burn one
[Laughter]
she
she wouldn't care if i like mess around
with my girlfriend in the living room
right
i think she'd prefer to watch yeah
she might want to videotape it yeah and
watch it later yeah
no you're right she'd be a very cool
stepmom maybe the only drawback would be
that my curfew would be like 6 p.m just
so she has plenty of time to watch me
and my girlfriend mess around
no way
now uh the movie stands for adult
children of divorce
and uh
it's it's it's getting a lot of
attention people really like this movie
the poster i've seen the poster out a
bunch of places uh for your movie there
it is yeah are you pleased with the
poster for the most part i really like
the poster it's it's i think it's really
cool i i mean it's flattering to be on a
poster um but what i learned very
quickly thanks to the internet is that
it's the perfect poster for drawing
on
[Applause]
in fact you have a demonstration yeah
remember the fcc ladies and gentlemen
has furloughed all of its workers so
they are off for the night yeah
i mean conan i think if any person
looking at this poster would just
immediately think
coming from the right of the poster
to be a perfect place for a
to come in
and aggressively shove itself into my
mouth
right there thank you so much for
drawing an arrow yeah
we all thank you for that wait your your
penis doesn't look like this
it did before the surgery
but but then you keep looking at it and
i think that coming from the left
is
as good if not better place for it to
come from to enter my mouth
but what i didn't realize
and again thanks to the internet is that
my hand is
it's
perfectly suited for
[Laughter]
so right there
and then
if you're particularly industrious that
can go all the way up
and then you know one can come yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i see it can just be a cacophony of
well uh that didn't occur to you while
you were making that poster at all while
you were at the photo shoot well they
photoshopped out all of those